si le lhc
sayah sabry au caire puis hop et
il a tenu un bar oui il était comment
c'est lui qui a fait le premier article
sur moi avant c'est ce que j'ai fait non
j'ai pris une gomme pour effacer mon nom
mais tellement j'étais il ya 10 bande de
cons acheter des deux premiers 10 de ce
saint divy duc ne galvaudera peut pas
encore gagnent leur imam
j'étais chez lui m'a dit vous savez ce
que quel est votre technique vous avez
la même technique que call center pour
les roger parti je ne vais pas revenir
les gars là les garçons bouchers sapin
qui paraît que je vois plus la même et
est même famille avant ils m'ont proposé
ici parce que je les aimais bien jeter
des invités michel il était bien très
bien où je suis production tu connais ça
toi il connaît pas au suivant un partout
ouais elle salue la copie tard maryland
chevaliers du ciel de 1,2 est ce que tu
ris quand je suis de bonne humeur ce
matin
si ma ville d'agneaux one
je savais où elle est à l'étude a dit ah
ouais ouais c'était un pote à moi
avant il était drôle à imiter sur milan
fief des turcs
il était avant était charmant plutôt
charmante équipe et en continu corte
zelko
ils vont devoir être que monsieur ne
serait ce qu'à dû la beauce équivalent
oui je vois plus la tulle m
il met à
alors à l'avant et tous à la paillade à
quoi quoi quoi mariano non en dari non
merde à celle internet non non tatata
way avec nos voisins continent mona elle
s'en sort bien
ouais c'était que le piège as-tu tomber
dans le piège cardio à la mort c'était
morelos était pas loin du mot allah dans
la main
alcool adore sharks et harry va le
prouver pour moi c'est voilà le canal la
sociaux où tous les côtés allez vas-y
mon petit larousse c'est très bien
voilà ça devient un peu plus dur la
campagne 1
bah oui mais ces adaptations ouais c'est
un mot est un vrai mais ça c'est en
france et zain est une merde kospi en
pente et oui le par ozil j y crois
vous savez pas vendu à l'est encore dans
ce pays qui fait lui pas très encore une
fois c'est du bal le parolier de lio je
te laisserais bien là et de l'état quand
un être hybride mauvais joueur alors de
mexes total des résultats si si si si si
c'est pas triste est que les projets ont
la même patrie scénario gascon et
connaître matrix et par your way l'ipo
et dario fo de la chance d'entrer très
bien c'est mario cette fois bravo et aux
antilles
un promu
de la ja
on
puis c'est qu'est la dernière chanson
qu'il a enregistré 1 alors que lens a
dit non je t'aime moi non plus sa
dernière folie loyer bio t'aime moi non
plus
pourquoi oiseaux vincenti ses sorties
mais on va le mettre dans le prochain
blind test on va vous rendez vous en
ville je t'aime moi non plus sur les
poils du chat d'après brigitte bardot et
au cap la version de bardos et c'est de
brûler parisienne ont été numéro 1 en
angleterre où le faire les appels dans
cette voie c'est beau la photo on peut
voir ça fait de la peine c'est l'amour
et non de bourvil aux forces de l'ordre
n'a vraiment à la promotion des régions
ces partis ont laissé passer trois jours
à garder son calme et point de vue c'est
la revue change jamais kwh de chaleur
des platanes
j'en chie
ça change plus c'est haut de gamme
sa pièce un récit sur un gros piège
grossier tg 1 franc jeu et qui
s'essayait écoute lui alloue verdes
oui à l'ovaire
occupy imitateurs au début j'avais pas
compris que c'était son imitateur un
imitateur
bon allez on avant-hier ils ont gagné
alors j'applaudis jamais connaître la
réponse